hi everyone um if you have looked at the
schedule you may be a little bit
confused my changing and evolving titles
I actually decided to change what I was
going to talk about uh last night
because I looked at the other talks that
people were giving here at the workshop
and I figured out that maybe uh this
work would be a better fit at least uh
to the current audience if you came here
expecting to hear about cyclic methods
um I can actually talk about that
offline I also have that talk I'm just
not going to talk about it
today okay so the work that I'll talk is
uh joint
work with uh my student pan Wang uh Niko
zerus he's a PhD student with ilas and
ilas with whom I shared the last name by
no accident uh this is actually the
first time elas and I
collaborated uh and we have been
together for 10 years the paper got in
oral presentation at icml so no not bad
although uh most credit should really go
to pan and Nikos who uh really did most
of the work on on this paper and I'm
very impressed with both of them so
let's uh start with the setup so uh
we're going to be working in the setup
which is known as agnostic learning of a
single neuron and now uh if you're not
someone who comes with a learning theory
background probably many of these words
don't make any sense so what I'm going
to do is now uh introduce what all of
this means so certainly you know what
linear regression would be so so here we
are not doing linear regression anymore
but nonlinear regression we um
after uh doing a linear transformation
we have some kind of
nonlinearity this W here is our model
parameter vector and the uh this thing
here called Sigma represents what is
known as an activation function or a
link function and uh it can be a value
that would be the most standard one and
actually I'll mostly talk about vales
but the work actually uh results apply
to much broader classes of activation
even including some non- monotone
activations like Swish and
G okay now in terms of you know what is
learning part here uh we assume that uh
we are getting some label
data and uh it is drawn from some
distribution that we do not know
importantly and why this is called
agnostic model we are not assuming
anything about the
labels okay so so there is no assumption
that the data corresponds to any model
whatsoever from our class we are just
trying to find the best
one okay so so for example if I'm
talking about values I'm trying to find
the best value the one that fits the
data the best okay you can also think
about it as uh there is some best vector
and then there is noise but this noise
is uh
arbitrary uh our goal and the reason why
there was a word regression there is to
approximately minimize the mean Square
loss of the model okay so so just the
what we are assigning to the data minus
the label and this
approximately what it means we'll see in
a little bit because U as you'll quickly
find
out there isn't that much we can hope
for let's see what we can actually do
what we can and cannot do so let's say
opt is the the minimum possible value of
this mean squared
loss now if you are an Optimizer and
you're trying to minimize some loss
function ideally you would like to
minimize that loss function to some
additive error Epsilon or multiplicative
error one plus
Epsilon if we are not making any
distributional assumptions even having
error of the type constant times op plus
Epsilon is actually an P heart and even
stronger uh Claims can be made about
improper learning where uh in fact super
polinomial time is required okay so so
this tells us uh even if all we are
shooting for is constant times opt plus
Epsilon we need distributional
assumptions now you can be thinking okay
but what if I have some really really
nice distribution in particular what if
I look at the nicest one of my
distributions just
gaussian
well uh even in that case it's not
working uh you cannot get additive
Epsilon that requires super polinomial
time there are lower bounds that tell us
that so in terms of approximation what
we can hope for is getting results of
the uh type constant times opt plus
Epsilon under distributional assumptions
so so both of these are required
okay so so now if we go back to the
problem statement we assume we have
sample access to some unknown but
structured distribution we have some
error parameter Epsilon and I'll just
confine my weight vectors to some uh
bounded set let's say it's an L2 ball of
radius W it doesn't really matter that
much
but the goal is to find a parameter
Vector of Norm atmost W such T that for
an absolute constant we want an absolute
constant here we do not want something
that scales with Dimension because
otherwise it quickly becomes
uninformative uh we get error c times op
plus Epsilon where you know again opt is
the minimum possible mean Square
loss okay and I'll immediately jump to
telling you what is the result and then
I'll go through more details about what
was known and and what we actually do
here so the main result is that under
mild distributional assumptions and I'll
tell you precisely what those
distributional assumptions are on the
next
slide we can run mini badge stochastic
gradient
descent for some sufficiently large
batch size and I'll tell you
specifically how large and a
sufficiently small step size but again
not too
small uh we don't run into the original
problem we run into an a surrogate
problem but we get guarantees for the
original
problem we solve the problem such that
for an absolute constant
C we get this uh Target error that we
want C * of plus Epsilon the number of
iterations is log 1 /
Epsilon the total number of samples that
the algorithm uses is D times some
function of one over
Epsilon uh quick remark this D has to be
there
like even for much easier problems like
if you look at standard gaussian
variance scales with d right so this has
to appear that this uh F of one over
Epsilon depends on the concentration of
onedimensional projections of the co
variat if you have subexponential
concentration it is a poly log in one
over
Epsilon if you have a heavy tailed
distribution if you have polinomial
Tales we can make them too heavy so so
the constant of the polinomial has to be
at least four then this is 1/ Epsilon to
2 over K so as uh K grows large this
becomes the whole thing becomes smaller
and this is always smaller than one over
root
Epsilon okay any questions about the
statement of the
result okay so so let's see now what the
distributional assumptions are uh there
are only
two what the first assumption you can
think of as a margin length assumption
it can also be interpreted as a type of
anti concentration but only in the
direction of one good
Vector okay so so concretely what we
assume is that there exists a parameter
Vector W star that gets error constant
times
opt and that there are some two absolute
constants gamma and
Lambda uh such that this condition holds
why is it the margin like condition well
if you are familiar with classification
this kind of looks like a
margin why is it anti concentration that
that requires a few lines
but that's the first uh assumption the
second assumption is about
concentration and uh in terms of
concentration we just uh assume if you
project on any direction the
concentration is better than one over um
t to the
fourth okay and then you see this for
the first time and you're wondering well
is this
mild it is in
fact uh these assumptions subsume
everything that was known and that can
achieve the same error guarantees and in
fact it contains many more uh
distributions okay so so let me give you
a more concrete
comparison so all prior work that could
get an absolute constant times op plus
Epsilon required all of the following
assumptions the first one is
anti-concentration
uh which roughly means that uh if you
look at one dimensional projections of
the covariates uh there is no interval
that contains too much of your
probability
Mass Okay the reason this is not an
ideal assumption to have is that uh
rolls out uh data that is potentially
lower
dimensional uh we relaxed this and we
only need anti concentration along one
of the approximate
Solutions okay there is concentration
and people I assume know what
concentration is so we want strong
concentration around the mean all prior
work required at least subexponential
concentration which uh rules out heavy
tail distributions and uh we replace
this with uh by allowing given
polinomial
fails the third assumption is what's
called anti- anti-concentration
uh the reason you would not want to have
an assumption like this is that it uh
rules out discrete distributions uh
anti-an concentration bouns the
probability density below so it doesn't
allow you to have uh any gaps in your
probability ma Mass so so so there is
there are no regions where you're not
placing it any
probability okay that assumption we
completely
remove okay so so so clearly these are
much weaker distributional assumptions
uh let me tell you a little bit more
about related work uh it will be
important for what we will discuss when
we go to main
ideas so there are two main lines of
work uh the first line of
work is uh applying algorithms like
stochastic gradient descent or gradient
descent on the empirical version
directly to this uh loss to the squared
loss which is what you're trying to
minimize and uh the way the results are
proved is that well if you're running
things like stochastic gradient descent
you're guaranteed to converge to a
stationary point so you prove a
stationary point is good
enough uh it's very nice it's a very
very natural approach um it would be
nice to prove such results under the
distributions that we
handle it appears quite challenging and
so far all the results that uh do things
like this they they require really
strong distributional
assumptions the second line of uh work
is uh for minimizing a convex surrogate
of the problem and this is what we do
and I'll tell you more about it uh soon
uh in terms of the results that actually
get an absolute constant uh times up
plus Epsilon uh only two of these uh
Works do that and uh they actually do
not handle any non- monotone activations
which are handled in
nwork and well the final thing I guess
that should always be a sanity check
when we specialize our results to the
setups that were handled by prior work
uh the sample complexity computational
complexity are not any higher they're
often much lower like going from poly 1
over Epsilon to poly log 1
Epsilon okay so I'll go to the main
ideas unless there are any
questions
okay so so I mentioned that there are
two main approaches looking at the
original squared loss and looking at the
convex surr and and some you know very
basic things uh that you can say about
these two types of loss functions well
the or original squared loss is
non-convex even if you look at just
value and value is your most basic
activation function uh it is what you're
what you want to minimize so obviously a
minimizer is a solution but a stationary
point is not a minimizer in general so
uh doing things like that are gradient
descent like are not guaranteed to give
you uh good approximate
Solutions the convex circuit that uh we
end up working with has actually been
used quite a bit on uh similar problems
in learning theory it was introduced
back in
1995 uh I know it may look a little bit
strange at first uh you should think
about what happens when you
differentiate it it starts looking quite
similar to what appears under the
squared loss
um that there is a better motivation
that one can also talk about through
Chow parameters but that's for much more
specialized audience so I chose not to
talk about that so so this uh circuit is
convex for any monotone activation uh
the minimizer may not be the solution so
so there there is no guarantee if you're
just generically minimizing this you get
the solution you need to prove more
results but it is convex so so gradient
descent will be converging to the
minimizer okay now the key
property that we prove and uh that
enables both this constant times opt
plus Epsilon
error and uh this very low sample and
computational
complexity
is provided in this
LMA so so what is this LMA saying uh if
we are making the distributional
assumptions that we are making there is
a set s and an absolute constant mu
uh such that the inner product of the
gradient of the surrogate loss with W
minus W star is bounded below by
quadratic so you can think of this as a
growth
condition uh in optimization things like
this are known as local Arrow bounds uh
we call it sharpness in our paper it's
not exactly sharpness so sharpness would
mean that the loss of w minus loss of w
star is bounded below by a quadratic uh
sharpness would imply this this is a
slightly weaker property things like
this certainly hold for strongly convex
functions uh but this does not imply
that the function is strongly conx it's
a weaker property is PL huh PL uh isn't
it
PL isn't it the pl condition so PL would
bound inequality restricted C I think
they call it uh probably there are other
names in the literature but PL I don't
see why it's immediately this becomes PL
because inequality
restricted probably name is not that
important let's put it I guess is people
haveen stuff under this RSI condition we
call it excellent so so let me comment
on that a little bit too uh so things
like local error bounds where you are
bounding some kind of residual function
by distance to the optimum uh these have
been studied in optimization theory for
a very long time uh since the
1950s uh in standard optimization Theory
people have usually looked at very broad
classes of problems uh and uh you know
proved even that things like this hold
generically the main issue is that this
constant here in those lower bounds is
usually not a constant it can be
exponentially small uh there are very
very few examples where you get an
absolute constant uh some examples come
in uh problems like Matrix sensing and I
think maybe even Matrix completion where
there are similar local Arrow bounds
that call but but it is very very rare
now you're probably wondering now okay
but what is this sets because maybe
useless uh
so the set s is a ball centered at zero
of radius to W star but it excludes
another ball around W star so so it has
this hole inside it and uh this
hole actually inside this hole uh all
the points have c times op error for a
constant C that depends on mu but mu is
an absolute constant so so we are
fine okay so so what will the actual
argument look like so so if you look at
the whole
region this is a region in which you can
show that uh manyi batch SGD would
contract Distance by a constant Factor
now if you know about stochastic
optimization this is not immediate from
things like sharpness because the
variance would be preventing you from
doing that but uh what we show is that
for a sufficiently large batch size your
variance of gradient estimate scales
with the distance to op squared so so
you actually do get a contraction in
this
region in this other region all the
points have error c times opt so so then
you know the basic argument is quite
simple you start at
zero uh you are in the bigger region so
when you're moving you're Contracting
the distance at some point you stepped
into this uh Target region you don't
know exactly when this
happens right and once inside this
region you may stay in or you may step
out but what we show is if you step out
you won't go far so there is slightly
larger ball where you will still have a
constant c times up so after log one
over Epsilon iterations you're always
within a ball where your error is
constant times up plus Epsilon yes is
this St like because uh it is not unique
we do not assume that it is unique we do
not assume even that the properties that
I stated hold for every W star only that
there is one for which it
holds doesn't matter which one just that
there is
one
okay so what we get our error guarantees
constant times up plus Epsilon for
agnostic learning of a single neuron and
uh the results apply to a large class of
activations and a much larger class of
distributions than what was handled in
prior
work the algorithm is both sample and
computationally efficient we recover all
prior results of a similar flavor and
actually improve over some of them and
handle many more
distributions uh and as I said we also
handle some non- monotone activations
like Gall and swish that were not
handled for power workor a couple of
open questions so so the first one is
that uh this property called the
sharpness or local Arrow bound is very
powerful but you need to be able to
prove it with the parameter with that
constant mu that is large enough
otherwise it's not very
useful now we already have a few
examples of uh machine learning problems
where we know how to prove such bounds
so maybe there is a broader phenomenon
maybe they're also telling us something
about the problems that problems that
are learnable perhaps have a very strong
signal in the data which would make
sense that an intuitive
level uh
other open questions of course concern
going beyond the single neuron so uh
let's say can we handle a sum of rues
and even though it seems like a mild
generalization uh actually the problem
becomes much more challenging and uh
even like for positive linear
combinations of values uh there are no
polinomial time algorithms that are know
I think there are not even known
polinomial time algorithms for sums of
values in the realizable case without
any
noise so that would be interesting now
since I have more time I can tell you a
little bit more about proving sharpness
but I want to First pause to see if
there are any uh
questions
yeah does your algorithm need to know M
for the sharpness no okay it does not
well let me see
[Music]
um it may need to know it to set the
batch size but in practice it wouldn't
matter so so the MU is not a constant
that we just show asymptotically like we
actually give a very concrete bound on
it uh based on distributional
assumptions I'm trying to
remember
um but yeah even if it does like this is
a thing because new only would play a
role in the batch size and the step size
which are things that people tune in
practice anyway
but what if you don't start in this
region s like imagine that you have
initialization that is like close to
some other Solutions what would would
you go to direction to this different W
star or it's unclear so so what is very
important about these uh results is that
we initialize at zero so because we're
initializing at zero we are guaranteed
to be in the set okay I got it that's
the yeah that's
trick okay but the question you should
be asking me is like how do you prove
this sharpness proper and uh since I
have I think four more minutes I could
go over
that and uh I I I'll do a simplified uh
proof that is uh just going to apply to
value is it simple enough to to discuss
uh here are the distributional
assumptions at the top and uh I'm going
to prove sharpness for the idealized
noise free circuit so why is it
idealized uh in the actual noise circuit
for which we can compute gradients uh
here you would have the label this is
something you don't
know uh however so so what we're going
to prove is sharpness of this thing on
the entire ball without that
exclusion uh that exclusion that that
Hollow part happens when you relate the
to this idealize the circuit to the
actual computable
circuit okay so so let's see how to
prove sharpness for this so let's just
start by writing things
down if you uh differentiate this what
you will be left with will be uh the
difference of the two sigmas multiplying
x times wus W star you just put X inside
and it looks like
this okay I I I trust this is something
you all can do in in like 30 seconds uh
now the sigma is a monotone function so
in fact if I put the absolute value here
uh this still holds just by
monotonicity okay so because now
everything is uh non negative under the
expectation uh if I condition on this
event I I surely have that inequality
right I'm just throwing away something
that is uh no
negative okay now let's see what to do
next so now I'm going to split this into
two possible cases where uh w.x is non-
negative and where it is
negative okay so far so
good and I have a value here so value
equals its argument when the argument is
non negative and it's zero when the
argument is negative okay so so now if
you so so because of this conditioning I
know exactly what R looks like right so
the first term is uh just going to be
this difference
squared the other term is going to have
w star. x times
this now look here for a
second if this event had some
non-trivial probability Mass
I could kind of ignore it and just look
at this and then my first margin like
condition would exactly give me what I
want it would be some constant times
Lambda time wus W star
squ okay it's just just from the first
condition up there has the same
conditioning but but the issue here now
is that I don't
know uh what the mass of this event
would
be right so so I need to consider both
so what happens in the rest of the proof
is that you look at this other case and
you argue using concentration that this
w.x uh is bounded below by a constant
times w.x minus w star.
x why is this true so in this case the
w.x and w.x they have different
signs so their difference is actually
the sum of absolute
values now this is going to be a
constant fraction of that difference uh
if this is not too
negative but this cannot become too
negative due to concentration and that's
the basic idea and then you're done
because you get that this is a constant
times
um uh times the quadratic difference you
have two complementary events you
multiply this one by the same constant
you're just relaxing sum them up use the
first condition and you're
done so that's a whole
proof how you generalize a different
question okay so I'll stop here than
questions
for you mentioned at some point that you
can do this for non-monotone sigment as
well okay so how different the proof is
then it's uh it requires you to
be requires you to be more um careful in
in how you're uh handling all all these
uh different quantities because some of
them may become negative but so you need
to ensure that they are dominated by
positive
terms okay so there will be some extra
assumptions then first so there are
assumptions on the activation functions
there are no additional assumptions
about the
distributions I guess more
precise more precisely are you saying
like the of non-monotonicity you can
tolerate is some function of the other
parameters in your problem okay yeah so
just
absorb for
this I was just trying to get some
intuition behind this anti-concentration
bound like if x is just a random like
isotropic gaussian and W is just some
fixed unit Vector like don't we expect
that event to very rarely happen like uh
I don't wouldn't we expect this
expectation to be very small because
it's rare that I would get a vector
that's pointing in a constant fraction
in the direction of some fixed Vector W
star like why is Lambda not scaling like
as one over root D or one over D or
something
umbe I'm just misunderstanding it no but
but uh here you're actually so so if
there was just a zero on the other side
you would be looking at the whole half
space right yeah uh here you are uh just
um reducing that space by a little but
there is still quite a non-trivial mass
so so you can uh you can argue not just
for gaans any isotropic Lo con caves you
can argue for discrete gaussians you can
argue for so even when gamma is like
some constant or something it is
actually we provide a specific constant
in the paper so so all of these are
derived for all the special cases
okay
thanks all right let's thank
y